il y a aussi des stars dans le bonbon
elisabeth voulu que le nounours et la
star oui tout à fait donc ce sont des
produits gélifiée ou gélatineux voyez
donc c'est la nouvelle génération
produit et ça connaît un très grand
succès et tellement de succès que la
société haribo société allemande qui
s'est installé en france il ya quelques
années est devenu le numéro un donc en
france et nous sommes rendus avec michel
viennent ou latos dans la plus grande
usine de france donc à marseille razer
le reportage nous sommes chez le plus
gros producteur de fraises du monde on
en récolte chaque année des milliards
ici en toute saison
une récolte magique puisque les fruits
gif en quelques instants
grâce au geste bien dosé du summer de
sucre et de syrie la presse à gabat
inventé ici qu'il y à 28 ans est
aujourd'hui de bonbons gélifiés le plus
mastiquer dans le monde tous ses fruits
tout ces figurines toutes ces bébêtes
gélatineuse ont le vent en poupe il dope
le marché malgré la vache folle et l'unl
en garde contre la gélatine
mais ici on utilise de la gestion des
ports malgré les colorants pas seulement
comme des petits pains mais ça ça va
plus vite les 15 40 ans en sont fous
les fabricants ont trouvé un bon filon
épauler varier à l'infini donc les
nouveautés sont très importantes et
axione considérablement le marché des
c'est vrai qu'on avale de plus en plus
vite
on a besoin d'être satisfait de plus en
plus vite aussi et donc c'est vrai que
j'ai dit fier nous aide beaucoup de ce
côté-là 120 tonnes de bonbons quittent
l'usiné tous les jours pour des
destinations multiples le réglisse n'est
pas une nouveauté mais maintenant il se
décline en plusieurs versions salée pour
les suédois ou bien rouge pour les
espagnols tout simplement parce que
c'est plus gai de toute façon les goûts
et les couleurs ça ne se discute pas